on ne va pas attendre plus longtemps
on va demander aux professeurs pierre
desproges ce qu'il pense du sportif
oui en fait j'ai dressé un portrait
psychosomatiques du sportif commun alors
tout d'abord on peut dire qu'on divise
les sportifs en trois grandes catégories
les mâles les femelles et les nageuses
est-allemande alors pour en venir
directement au mode de vie du sportif
commun comme l'homme le sportif est un
mammifère il se reproduit donc comme
l'homme quand le sportif sans monter en
lui l'appel irrésistible du désir c'est
plus fort que lui il faut qu'il aille au
stade alors il va au stade et ça passe
moins imaginative la femme du sportif
sentant grandir en elle l'appelle du
désir va aux coiffeurs et non pas chez
le coiffeur où ils risqueraient de
rencontrer la coiffeuse déçu on dénombre
en france cinq grandes espèces de
sportif le cycliste d'abord qui est très
importante
le civiliste moyen est viscéralement
sous doués d'ailleurs il a la tête plus
bas que le cul surtout dans les côtes
on peut l'observer assez facilement au
lit comme à bicyclette la
caractéristique du cycliste et qu'il
espère faire mieux la prochaine fois
le cycliste à une seconde peau qui
s'appelle le maillot jaune c'est un
simple maillot de type jean-edern
hallier c'est à dire que on le voit très
bien l'image même de très loin et qui
s'enlève tout seul
le tennis aussi d'autre part le tennis
est un sport noble mais ennuyeux comme
on a pu en juger
récemment l'écoutant le commentaire
radiophonique de la finale de roland
garros
ces villas skipass haviland air qui
passa ville à ce qu'ils fassent alors là
c'est un peu chiant la boxe maintenant
pour ce monsieur et demi sur le plateau
on a beaucoup mais 10 de la boxe on a
même prétendu que les anciens boxeurs à
la retraite devenaient de véritables
épaves humaine
c'est complètement faux il existe des
anciens boxeurs heureux il laisse
tranquillement pif le chien en braille
et tout va mieux pour eux alphonse
halimi réagir
les courses non je ne reviens que tout à
l'heure c'est bien gentil pour changer
pour changer venons en aux courses qui
sont le sport le plus distingué en
france les hippodromes d'ailleurs sont
plaints de bi gomme et de vieilles
baronne en perd deux et qui regardent
des nains bariolés filer des coups de
pompe dans le bide à des canassons
lanceur qui leur ont rien fait c'est
baronne achètent leurs perles avec
l'argent des allocations familiales que
les besogneux vienne claqué aux courses
c'est le sport national français
le football maintenant bien que
l'essentiel de son savoir-faire se situe
au niveau de ses pieds le footballeur
est également fort bien musclé du haut
on cite notamment le cas du footballeur
platini dont le tour de poitrine atteint
118 cm cent dix huit centimètres entre
le thème est le deuxième haut de
marlborough et à drôle de regard des
sportifs la roja ouais ouais
pour finir il ya une question que l'on
peut se poser y at il une intelligence
du sportif oui il drut n'ont rien elle
est sensiblement d'ailleurs la même si
le footballeur le tennisman le jockey le
cheval ou le boxeur le quotient
intellectuel du sportif moyens et voisin
de celui de l'autre russe d'ailleurs si
l'autre us baissent la tête c'est pas du
tout pour se l'offrir dans le sable
c'est pour avoir l'air d'un coureur
c'est bien connu
pour finir un chiffre le record mondial
du plus bas quotient intellectuel c'est
un sportif est détenu actuellement par
le soviétique youri corsi kof
c'est lui qui a tenté en vain d'ailleurs
d'imposer aux derniers jeux olympiques
le lancement du poing sur glace